hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
Stanley parable are you ready to have
your brains look as we're gone what
could it mean you just interrupted me
I'm seeing simply mister how dare you
okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to let's
play to Stanley parable are you ready to
have your brains explode out your ears
well get ready because it's gonna happen
the adventure line where was that
adventure line I saw him before
you can't run a war okay that's just an
open door there's open doors all over
the place behind the scenes here and I'm
pretty sure that I could get to them
somehow and I don't know where but the
adventure line go I know I saw him him I
say him when Stanley came to a set of
two open doors uh-huh he entered the
door on his left you got it buddy see
here I know I I saw I know I saw it
dabble it what happened to the adventure
line I don't know yet there was not a
single person here either mmm meaning a
wave of disbelief Stanley decided to go
up Stanley stepped into the broom closet
but there was nothing here so he turned
around
wait a minute with staircase Stanley
walked upstairs to his boss's office
wait a minute why is it why did it loop
why didn't it go like her you been in
that broom closet before was going on is
that a button no that is a light all
right let's see what's down here I'm
been down here yet though but Stanley
just couldn't do it he considered the
possibility of facing his boss ah
admitting he had left his post during
work hours so Gary might be fired for
that yeah and in such a competitive
economy why had he taken that risk all
because he went to be four had vanished
his boss would think he was crazy yeah
and then something occurred to stand me
why maybe he thought to himself maybe I
am crazy
oh let my co-workers blinking
mysteriously out of existence in a
single moment for no reason at all
none of it made any logical sense and I
only pondered this he began to make
other strange observations like while
example why couldn't he see his feet
when he looked uh ah why did bowels
close automatically behind him wherever
he went oh and for that matter these
rooms were starting to look pretty
familiar yeah were they simply repeating
no Stanley said to himself this is all
too strange this can't be real at last
he came to the conclusion that had been
on the tip of his tongue ah just hadn't
found the words for it what is it I'm
dreaming oh this is all a dream curse
what my servant to have finally found an
answer an explanation his co-workers
weren't actually gone I wasn't going to
lose his job and crazy after all
oh no to himself I suppose I'll wake up
soon I'll have to go back to my boring
real life job pushing buttons I may as
well enjoy this while I'm still lucid
I'd say Celso he imagined himself flying
and began to gently flip off the ground
ah fly
then he imagined himself sorry base on a
magical star field and it too appeared
whoa so much fun that's Danny marveled
that he had still not woken up holding
so lucid I don't know then perhaps the
strangest question of them all entered
Stanley's head yeah he was amazed he
hadn't asked him so sooner why why is
there a voice in my head dictating
everything that I'm doing and thinking
what now the voice was describing itself
being considered by Stanley who found it
particularly strange I'm dreaming about
a voice describing me thinking about how
it's describing my thoughts hey Amani
thought it all very old if this voice
spoke to all people in their dreams it
was that of course this was not a dream
how could it be what stan is simply
deceiving himself
believing that if he's asleep he doesn't
have to take responsibility for himself
Stanley is as awake right now as he's
ever been in his life now hearing the
voice speak these words shocked see
after all he knew for certain beyond a
doubt that this was in fact a dream did
the voice don't see him flow to make the
magical stars just a moment ago how else
would the voice explain all that his
voice was a part of himself - surely
only if he could just he would prove it
he would prove that he was in control
that this was a dream so he closed his
eyes gently only invited himself to wake
yeah he's not the cool weight of the
blanket on his skin the press of the
mattress on his back the fresh air of a
world outside this one let me wake up he
thought to himself I'm through with this
dream mother I wish it to be over I'll
go let me go back to my job let me
continue pushing the button ok please
see it's all I want I want my apartment
and my wife a wire my job want it all I
want is my life exactly the way it's
always been my life is normal normal I
am normal me everything will be fine I
am ok
I'm not okay am I
ah
Stanly began screaming someone Stanley
ah boss I have an office
ah you please just someone tell me I'm
real human and everything went black
well good I died this is the story of a
woman named Mariela what Mariela woke up
on a day like any other
she rose got dressed gathered her
belongings and walked to her place of
work
oh but on this particular day her walk
was interrupted by the body of a man who
had stumbled through town talking and
screaming to himself and then collapsed
dead on the sidewalk and although she
would soon turn to go call for an
ambulance for just a few brief moments
she considered the strange man he was
obviously crazy this much she knew
everyone knows what crazy people look
like and in that moment she thought to
herself how lucky she was to be normal I
am saying I am in control of my
I know what is real and what isn't it
was comforting to think this and in
certain way seeing this man made her
feel better but then she remembered the
meeting she had scheduled for that day
the very important people whose
impressions of her would affect her
career and by extension the rest of her
life she had no time for this so it was
only a moment that she stood there
staring down at the body and then she
turned and ran
my brain my brain what happened my brain
yeah if his co-workers were gone what
could it mean Stanley decided to go to
the meeting room
perhaps he had simply missed a memo yeah
it's different things I'm done
oh no my brain mm-hmm my brand one
Stanley came to a set of two open doors
he entered the door on his left okay you
got it buddy are things different now
that's the same what's going on what's
going on yet there was not a single
person here either
feeling a wave of disbelief Stanley
decided to go up to his boss's office
hoping he might find an answer there
okay maybe what about the broom closet
oh no oh no no no no no no no no no no
not again I won't be part of this okay
encourage you I'm not going to say
coming to a staircase Stanley walked
upstairs what's to his bosses but what
happens but what would happen if I what
would happen if I this is just gonna is
it just gonna this is just gonna do this
in the head Louie do something different
here we go but Stanley just couldn't
yeah oh crap it's gonna be the same
thing again boss admitting he had left
his post dressed Oz no person for that
and in such a job yes I did it again had
he taken that oh no I did it again
leaved
everyone I did it his boss would think
he was crazy and then something occurred
does it it again maybe he thought to him
okay I'm gonna zoom past this part racy
BRB workers blink I'm not crazy I'm
perfect
I gotta leave in a Jean
and one night me there's no black man
where's little black man okay oh there
was happened but we're back in the name
Norma shot ah it was only a matter of
time before you my brain what everything
hurts just a matter is the adventure
line I know I saw the adventure line
somewhere here I know it was here
whatever I don't care I'm gonna make a
different choice I'm gonna do something
different something out of the ordinary
that you're not gonna do Stanley came
shut your mouth Lupin this was not the
correct way don't care and standing you
in perfect I know your face perhaps he
wanted to stop by the employee lounge
first that's where it was that's where
the adventure line was but it's not
there right now yes what is going on but
eager to get back to business
Stanley took the first open door on his
left no no no no no no no no no no no
what I'm gonna do was so bad it forgot a
shadow of a doubt Olivos is gonna go
over there I went over there I'm gonna
go over there Stanny
I think perhaps we've got enough on the
room Giada I'm not your heaven yes you
are
I realize that invested in your trust in
someone else can be difficult the effect
is that the story has been about nothing
but you all this time my - there's
someone you've been neglecting Stanley
someone you forgotten
please stop trying to make every
decision by yourself hey I'm not asking
for me I'm asking for her who's her wait
a minute who's her this is it Stanley
your chance to redeem yourself to put
your work aside to let her back into
your life who's her she's been waiting
who's her my compy okay who's her know
who her is mad with my brake pad dark
cigarette butts all right here we go
that's her Stanley you need to be the
one to do this to reach out if you can
truly place your faith in another then
pick up the phone
hey what is that you hold on sweetie
sorry to keep you waiting
I'm just pulling the bread out of the
oven oh right okay there we go
all right now I want you to come in and
tell me all about you do mmm oh oh come
on
did you actually think you had a loving
wife who want to commit their life to
you hmm
I'm trying to make a point here Stanley
and trying to get you to see something
come inside
yeah let me show you what's really going
no Merrigan no but you're in my story
now oh oh that's how it's gonna be bits
oh I see
all right fine then go in the mmm I
don't have choice anymore
uh-oh things are gone whoo this is a
very sad story about the death of a man
named Stanley Yeow
family is quite a boring fellow he has a
job that demands nothing of heat every
button that he pushes is a reminder of
the inconsequential nature of his
existence
hmm and I can't move anywhere what am i
doing I can't do anything it's all
blocked up
hello loving wife mannequin where's my
wife got to be a mannequin hey I can't
do anything I can't dad anything I
literally cannot do anything right this
is blocked up here TVs block furnished
it's all askew what a kid please press H
oh okay
look at him they're pushing buttons
doing exactly what he's trying to do I
didn't how he's pushing a button now
he's eating lunch now he's going home
whoa no he's coming back to work what
one might even feel sorry for him except
that he's chosen this life with it
when did this change what he but in his
mind
ah in his mind he can go on fantastic
adventures from behind his desk
Stanley dreamed of wild expeditions into
the unknown fantastic discoveries of new
lands it was wonderful and each day that
he returned to work was a reminder that
none of it would ever happen to him
okay mr. M to watch TV okay and so he
had to fantasize about his own job first
he imagined that one day while at work
he stepped out from his desk to realize
that all of his co-workers his boss
everyone in the building had suddenly
vanished off the face of the earth
the thought excited him terribly
Oh spend time with the boys okay so he
went further he imagined that he came to
to open doors and that he could go
through either at last choice it barely
even mattered what lay behind each door
the mere thought that his decisions
would mean something was almost too
wonderful to behold
is he wonderful
fantasy world he began to fill it with
many possible paths and destinations ah
down one pathway an enormous round room
with monitors and mind controls and down
another was a yellow line that weaved in
many directions I remember on another
was a game with a baby I didn't call it
the Stanley parable okay it was such a
wonderful fantasy and so in his head he
relived it again and then again and
again over and over
wishing beyond hope that it would never
end that he might always feel this free
ah holy there's an answer down some new
path mustn't happy perhaps if he played
just one more time I love you girls no
answer oh girl there possibly be in
reality of all he's doing is pushing the
same buttons he always has I don't know
it was changed I know it is lower he
spends here the more invested he gets no
it is the more he forgets which life is
the real one oh good asleep and I'm
trying to tell him this that in this
world he can never be anything but an
observer that as long as he remains here
he's slowly killing himself but he won't
listen to me
he won't stop here what's this Stanley
the next time the screen asks you to
push a button do not do it I'm doing it
yeah you see Ark just not hear me how
can I tell him in a way that he'll
understand that every second he remains
here is electing to kill himself how can
I get him to see what I see how can I
make him look at himself
oops
II W remove she escaped
yeah suppose I can't not in the way I
want him to but I don't make the rules
didn't any blubbers the same as steel
and also do her I'll try once more
didn't veil this to him I'm compelled to
I must perhaps well maybe this time
you'll see maybe it's time and I tried
again never happened Stanley pushed a
button
no and I tried again yeah and Stanley
pushed a button no and I know
you killed me you bastard oh but brain
yeah sorry got a little brain in my
headphones God okay that's enough for
this episode I'm gonna go again
this game is awesome by the way if you
haven't gotten here you need to get it
there's so many things here so many
avenues to explore I know where I'm
going next so thank you so much for
watching
huh wait what did I do that wrong
who's that exactly how I did it before
yo remember bye-bye that's normal I need
to find a bucket filled with water
Wham
that's important
oh there yeah
bud
let's see my here
or or